shane mitchell how you doing hello
i'm so good how are you
i'm so good this is my first time
talking to you you're one of my favorite
people to follow on social media love
pretty little liars so this is kind of a
special moment
this baby showed up at my doorstep i
love yes i am glorious i feel so
feminine like right now
but it's sexy it's like approachable
it's honestly just the perfect balance
yay i'm so happy you like it yeah no i
immediately i was like yes this is my
kind of scent now is it true that one of
the scents is milkshakes
that set exactly it's like all of the
perfect scents i mean you have peach in
that magnolia with an undertone of
sandalwood and then the vanilla
milkshake so who doesn't like any of
those exactly exactly well i was going
to ask you your favorite milkshake but
i'm assuming it's vanilla like i'm a
strawberry vanilla but honestly if you
handed me strawberry chocolate i
wouldn't turn it down so yeah as long as
it has milkshake following it i'll drink
it yeah
for the strawberry milkshakes from
mcdonald's it's really bad they're so
thick but they're so good so good
[Laughter]
um you know it's so fun following you on
social media i mean it's wild that you
have over 30 million of followers you
exude such a positive energy you've
become a role model to a lot of women
out there do you find that this brand
like really aligns with that a hundred
percent and that's why i mean partnering
with cash rail not only is it you know
has been such a timeless brand i always
say it's so crazy because i remember
seeing a perfume bottle from casual on
my mom's dressing table like when i was
growing up and then when i partnered
with them she was like that's so cool i
had it i'm like i know so it's you know
a really cool moment that now i'm able
to be able to wear the product and i
mean the perfume is just so amazing so
it's nice
yeah that's pretty wild that your mom
had a proofing bottle like when you were
younger and so i'm just like yeah full
circle it's really neat
yeah
yeah well you know just obviously on
social media uh you're just so relatable
and people cannot get enough
of atlas how would you say your daughter
has really changed you how has mother
had changed you
it's just been the most enriching part
of my life i mean she's incredible and i
will probably hear her throughout this
but
it's so fun you know it's like every day
i wake up excited to see what else she's
going to say or learn or do
and every day is different and it's just
it's wild it's it's been the best fry
that i've ever been it's amazing yeah is
it what you expect it
it's everything and more and i know that
that sounds so cheesy to be like it's
everything more but it really is i mean
i had an idea of what it would be like
but it's just ten times more fun and
crazy at times but it's good yeah she's
so much fun
i mean i can only imagine how many
moments that have been so special that
you two have been able to share together
but is there a certain moment that will
always be you know something that you
look back on and have such fond memories
when it comes to time that you've spent
with atlas
i think honestly this past year you know
the silver lining of you know all of
last year was being able can you hear it
um was being able to have all of this
time to spend with her i don't know if i
would have had that if we weren't you
know forced to be inside and so it's
also been you know the one thing that's
been really amazing about this past year
is just the time we've been able to
spend with her
so amazing quality time but not as many
shaycation videos which we all love so i
mean aside from having this wonderful
time with your daughter do you miss
traveling
absolutely i miss being home in canada
you know like i'm not going home as
often as i used to um so yes i am but
i'm excited for when everything is open
and safe to do so i will definitely be
over canada will be my first stop but
yeah of course i miss traveling and i
can't wait to travel the world with her
yeah that would be so nice is there a
spot that you just can't wait to check
out aside from canada and coming home
and having all your favorite canadian
snacks which is always so much fun to
see on your instagram oh yeah
the ketchup chips but is there a place
in in the world that you just would love
to go
honestly taking her to italy probably
because i was pregnant when i was there
with her and i just think it would be
full circle to go back there with her
and see her enjoy pizza from there
instead of the ones that i make here
so yeah i would love to take her to
italy maybe that will be the first spot
that we go
listen i i watch your tortilla pizza
video i want to do that now
all my italian friends weren't that
impressed but i mean hey it was like the
low part low carb edition yeah no it's
so good i'm like that's so genius i'm
gonna do that
you also have killer uh workout videos i
mean you posted this boxing one you're
so badass in this i mean if you have the
chance would you want to get into that
marvel dc universe and be a superhero i
mean one thousand percent i think that's
like on my top top bucket list to be
able to do just because i think the
training and leading up to that movie
would almost be as much fun as shooting
it yeah um i love it i love training i
love being active and i love switching
it up and there's just such a like
confidence booster i have from you know
after a good session at boxing you just
feel so much stronger and it helps so
i'm having to carry around like a 30
pound little bowling ball you know
i love her
um you know
obviously we all try to stay as positive
as possible but this past year has been
really challenging for a lot of people
so when you're feeling down do you have
any advice for people if you know to
just keep going and staying positive
honestly i think talking about it i
really any time i'm feeling upset or
just like not the best i honestly just
pick up the phone and talk to friends
and family i think expressing how you
feel is always a good thing and
releasing that so i always love to just
pick up the phone or do a facetime um
you know i've been doing that a lot in
the past year especially with my grandma
so we do a little facetime stuff she has
it in her room so even though i'm not
able to be there in person it's still
fun we can do our little workouts
together and yeah so i think just
staying connected to people not
isolating yourself as much as you can
you have such a special relationship
with her oh my gosh i know it's crazy
i'm like water works every time so i
can't talk about it too much
my best friend i know and it's such a
special relationship that i've had with
her and i'm so lucky but yeah she's
definitely my everything
no i mean you just know listen though
you just know people feel like they know
her when they follow you people feel
like somebody and i'll you know explain
to her sometimes i'm like hey that video
that we did people thought that was
really funny like a lot of people saw it
she's like a lot of it did i have my
hair done i'm like oh my gosh yes bran
you looked amazing
i can only imagine how busy you are you
know you've got so much on the go you
have face this amazing luggage line that
there are so many people who love to
review how much they love this luggage
line online anda is doing super well so
so hard to be okay with
yeah
so how are you managing all this
it's just it's it's doing things
that you feel passionate about doing i
love it every single day i mean i could
do
meeting after meeting for base and for
different partnerships that i love being
a part of because i
am just so passionate about all of them
so it never really feels like work to be
honest with you and i think it's just
finding that time i've you know since
having atlas been able to prioritize my
time a little bit better and figure out
how to do that to the best of my ability
but
i'm having just fun and i feel so
fortunate to be able to work on things
that i feel this strongly about yeah do
you always get a little bit nervous
before you put something up there into
the world to see how people react
because people react so positively well
to anything you put out
but i honestly think it goes back to
just it all being you know genuine
either partnerships or products that i'm
putting out there you know that they've
all been tried and tested and never back
anything that i don't fully believe in
so i think you know
the audience that follows me definitely
knows that whatever it is that i'm
talking about something yeah yeah and it
must feel pretty nice too you know
having uh you know a young girl having a
daughter that you get to be this role
model that you're showing her i'm an
entrepreneur we're just showing her that
hey you can do whatever you you know put
your mind to when you work really hard
you know and she definitely sees it the
other day she was like on that and
carried it to me i was like this is
amazing ambassador exactly exactly
okay so obviously with everything else
going on let's talk about acting is
there any upcoming things into the
acting world tv film we just love seeing
you
yeah we're currently in the middle of
shooting season two for doll face which
is so much fun so i'm getting to be able
to you know play stella who i absolutely
love and i'm back with the girls of
course so it's so much fun you know it's
a little different under these
circumstances but it's still so fun to
be back on set i really missed it
that's so great oh yeah i just had so
much fun talking to you like this is so
fun
i'm just so in awe of all the things
that you're working on and you always
just look like you're having a good time
it's so fun i am i really have nothing
to complain about you know at the end of
the day i get to work on really cool
brands um with really awesome people so
it's like just
have fun and don't take anything too
serious you know yeah that's good advice
that's good because i think people can
get hung up on little things you know
100
yeah absolutely no thank you so much for
chatting with me
you